small protests in the second largest
city in myanmar
these students and activists in mandalay
are speaking out against monday's
military coup
but with the military clamping down on
internet and social media providers
it's hard for people to communicate and
organize protests
we have no access to any news no news
about mother aung
tsuchi i feel so sad it gives me a pain
in my chest
i would rather go out and fight if
possible but that would be against the
wishes of mother sue
facebook is a central part of life in
myanmar it's why the military has shut
it down
it seems as if the military has really
gone after the primary social media
platforms including
facebook which really is the internet in
myanmar most people including people
within
government agencies use facebook almost
as if uh
it was an email system so it will be uh
terrible in terms of its consequences
not only in terms of organizing a
response to this coup
but also in terms of conducting
day-to-day business
and economic activity but that didn't
stop these health workers walking out of
a hospital to protest against the coup
according to their facebook groups
similar walkouts happened at hospitals
across the country
we are just protesting peacefully by
wearing this red ribbon
we don't need to speak out we all know
that wearing the ribbon is a sign of
protest against the military government
and we only want our elected government
this
is our message many people have likely
not seen such a military presence on
their streets
since the 2011 democratic reforms
despite their apparent anger at the
social media ban and the international
condemnation of the coup
the generals who have vast business
interests in the country
are not going anywhere many people in
myanmar may be troubled by the military
intervention
but minorities in the country have long
been victims of the army's crackdown
hundreds of thousands of muslim rohingya
were forced to flee persecution
deposed leader aung sang sushi who was
largely silent about their plight
now finds herself at the mercy of the
very same generals
assad bake al jazeera